das sind 800 quadratmeter
die bundesländer legen den neuen corona
bestimmungen für den einzelhandel
unterschiedlich aus sicherheitsregeln am
arbeitsplatz das kabinett beschließt
vorgaben damit sich möglichst niemand
beim arbeiten ansteckt notprogramm als
normalfall kindern und eltern fehlt die
betreuung in den kitas
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten die heute damit
beginnen wie das land ab montag ein
wenig freiraum zurückgewinnt denn
deutschland macht wieder auf ganz
vorsichtig schritt für schritt denn
niemand will ja gefährden was bisher
gegen die pandemie erreicht wurde
nach den beschlüssen von bund und
ländern gestern gibt es viel zustimmung
aber auch kritik zum beispiel im
einzelhandel
da dürfen ja ab montag autohäuser
fahrradläden und buchhandlungen wieder
öffnen
außerdem geschäfte mit einer
verkaufsfläche bis zu 800 quadratmetern
das entspricht dem kleinen teil eines
fußballfelds willkürlich sagen einige
und ungerecht gegenüber größeren läden
peter kunst berichtet abstand zum kunden
in manchem geschäft wird das schwer
fallen beim verkauf von unterwäsche mit
fachberatung zum beispiel kommt man sich
näher als corona erlaubt ich muss ja
diese hand zu machen und hinten den
träger einstellen
und ich sehe eigentlich sofort ob der bh
zu klein ist oder zu groß ist und dann
gehe ich ihm das nächste teil holen
aber man ist schon mit dem menschen sehr
dicht umdenken im fachhandel monika
fonds rettet ihren laden über die zeit
indem sie den stammkunden anprobe pakete
nach hause schickt sebastian rechenbach
bringt schutzfolien an aber er darf erst
einmal nicht öffnen sein textilgeschäft
in hannover ist zu groß über 800
quadratmeter meine große hoffnung geht
ja noch in die richtung dass wir
vielleicht teilbereiche öffnen können
dass wir zum beispiel das erdgeschoss
öffnen und den ersten stock damenwäsche
das sind dann auch unter 800
quadratmeter
das wäre nur fair weil alles andere ist
schwer zu verstehen diese 800
quadratmeter sind in unseren augen rein
willkürlich gewählt und als freie lösung
völlig ungeeignet für die beurteilung
von gefährdungen in geschäften händler
rechenbach fände es sinnvoller eine
maximale personenzahl pro 100
quadratmeter laden größe vorzuschreiben
einkaufen erlaubt oder verboten wird ein
bundesweites corona puzzle
große kaufhäuser und einkaufszentren wie
hier in münchen bleiben allerdings
vorerst überall zu wenn ich ihn sehe
eine unkontrollierte fußgängerzone
auch wenn es kleine geschäfte sind wir
können es gut kontrollieren wir haben
sicherheitskräfte im haus wir haben
alles darum wirklich genau das zu
erfüllen was es heißt und dann würde ich
sagen fühlen wir uns ungerecht behandelt
ja warum also dürfen kleine die großen
aber nicht warum diese zahl der 800 es
ist ein kompromiss der große teile des
handels abdeckt der aber eben auch die
verlässlichkeit gebietet dass wir nicht
massen anfang an bestimmten stellen in
den städten gekommen können ansturm
vermeiden markus söder will in bayern
noch vorsichtiger sein als andere
im freistaat dürfen auch geschäfte unter
800 quadratmetern
erst eine woche später auf machen als im
rest der republik
sabine günther betroffen von diesen
sonderweg hat verständnis
gefahrenquellen in anführungsstrichen
italien dran und unsere fallzahlen sind
zwar schon runter gang aber sind immer
noch da und wir können uns nicht
vergleichen mit mecklenburg vorpommern
oder schleswig holstein
in einem aber ist bayern ab montag teil
eines einheitlichen einkaufs deutschland
baumärkte und gartencenter dürfen dann
auch hier wieder öffnen
ganz egal wie groß
in leeden wird also bald wieder mehr
personal gebraucht und auch in vielen
firmen und fabriken müssen arbeitskräfte
vor ort seien nicht alles geht vom home
office aus
umso wichtiger dass dann am arbeitsplatz
auch die hygiene stimmt das
bundeskabinett hat heute neue
verbindliche empfehlungen beschlossen
zum schutz der mitarbeiter vor
infektionen
patricia wedemeyer hat die einzelheiten
1,5 meter abstand desinfizieren und
mundschutz in baumärkten und den
kleineren läden die derzeit offen sind
wird all das längst praktiziert künftig
soll es überall gelten bundesweit und
verbindlich arbeitsminister heil stellte
heute in berlin maßnahmen für einen
branchenübergreifenden arbeitsschutz vor
durch die gestern zwischen bund und
ländern vereinbarten lockerung werden
jetzt auch viele menschen an den
arbeitsplatz zurückkehren
deshalb ist das wichtigste signal des
heutigen tages des arbeitsschutz
gesundheitsschutzes
wer diesen zeiten arbeitet braucht
besonderen schutz bei der arbeit in
gebäuden im freien und in fahrzeugen
soll ein sicherheitsabstand von 1,5
metern eingehalten werden beschäftigte
sollen möglichst wenig direkten kontakt
haben und wo es keine schutzscheiben
gibt und abstände nicht eingehalten
werden können muss der arbeitgeber einen
nasen mundschutz waschgelegenheiten und
desinfektion spender bereit stellen für
viele unternehmen sind die
schutzmaßnahmen nicht das problem dieser
herausforderung stellen sich die
betriebe das ist kein leichtes
unterfangen aber das kriegt die
wirtschaft auch hin wichtig ist die
perspektive dass wieder es beginnen kann
doch erstmal geht es nur für einige
wenige weiter friseurläden dürfen zum
beispiel ab dem vierten mal wieder
öffnen hier die neuen arbeitsschutz
regeln einzuhalten eine echte
herausforderung zur corona krise sehen
sie heute auch ein zdf spezial die
folgen für die industrie direkt im
anschluss an unsere nachrichten für
weitere informationen empfehlen wir
ihnen die zdf- heute- app dort finden
sie neben einem live blog weitere zahlen
und grafiken zu kitten
werfen wir wie jeden tag jetzt einen
blick darauf wie sich die korona
infektionszahlen in deutschland
entwickeln stand 18 uhr 30 sind in
deutschland laut johns hopkins
universität 135 1633 infektionen durch
tests bestätigt davon gelten 77 tausend
menschen als genesen 3850 starben in
verbindung mit cupid 19
eine weitere zahl auf die jetzt alle
besonders gespannt schauen ist die
sogenannte re produktionszahl was sie
bedeutet erklärt uns anselm stern
die erfolge im kampf gegen das virus sie
seien zerbrechlich mahnt die regierung
bei der frage ob die lage unter oder
außer kontrolle ist blickten viele auf
die sogenannte re produktionszahlen
aktuell liegt die in deutschland
schätzungsweise bei 1 jeder infizierte
steckt also aktuell eine weitere person
an
und das heißt wir haben keine klare
abnahme oder keine klare zunahme des
virus in der in also der zahl der
infizierten und das hat zur folge dass
wir in dem gesundheitssystem unsere
kapazitäten nicht überschreiten werden
nach unseren berechnungen aber schon
ganz kleine veränderungen der re
produktionszahl hätten wohl enorme
auswirkungen
die regierung rechnet bei 1,1 könnte das
gesundheitssystem im oktober an seine
belastungsgrenze kommen in der praxis
würde das bedeuten sehr viele kranke und
zu wenig intensivbetten bei 1,2 wäre das
bereits im juli der fall bei 1,3 schon
im juni bei unseren abschätzung ist es
so dass wir bei 13 in zwei bis drei
monaten tatsächlich ein riesentyp haben
mit einer million belegten betten in den
krankenhäusern
ein szenario von dem das
gesundheitssystem derzeit aber weit
entfernt ist die krankenhäuser melden
heute mehr als 11.000 freie
intensivbetten mit dem nötigen personal
mehr personal sollen die
gesundheitsämter in deutschland bekommen
um schneller kontaktpersonen von
infizierten finden zu können ein
gesundheitsamt muss eigentlich melden
sind das menschen in welchem alter an
welcher stelle in welchem ort des
bereits des gesundheitsamtes und wenn
sie dann sehen sie haben einen
infektionsfall in einem altersheim oder
sie haben etwas in einer berufssituation
oder an einer schule dann können sie
natürlich ganz anders vorgehen und auch
die schutzmaßnahmen ganz anders machen
schutzmaßnahmen die helfen sollen den
antivirus kampf in deutschland weiter zu
beschleunigen
für millionen schülerinnen und schüler
und viele eltern geht das homeschooling
also das unterrichten zu hause erstmal
weiter mindestens noch zwei wochen das
haben bund und länder gestern so
vereinbart ab dem vierten mai sollen
schulen dann schrittweise mit dem
unterricht beginnen
angefangen mit abschluss und prüfungs
klassen einige länder aber haben bereits
angekündigt schon eine woche vorher zu
starten
noch weit entfernt vom normalbetrieb
bleiben kitas die sind inzwischen
ausschließlich für eine notbetreuung
geöffnet für erzieherinnen erzieher und
kinder eine große herausforderung sven
ricke bilder und greta sind heute morgen
die beiden einzigen kinder in der kita
die bälle im norden von hamburg zählt er
wird vier sie feiert ihren geburtstag
alleine mit ihrer schwester und zwei
erzieherinnen zur normalen zeiten wäre
160 weitere kinder um sie herum
die vermissen das total und die sozialen
kontakte vermissen sie so sehr dass wenn
sie denn irgendwo auf der straße mal
jemanden sehen dann ist es schwer den
abstand auch einzuhalten aber sie machen
es gut unsere kinder morgens gut
kinder halten keinen abstand so viel ist
klar
das aber muss kein hindernis sein wenn
sich die kitas doch weiter öffnen und
die gruppen klein bleiben
die politik hat erst mal gesagt weiter
so aber auch klar gestellt dass die
bedürfnisse der bundesländer
unterschiedlich sind
wir wollen bei der notbetreuung bleiben
es sollen aber weitere bedarfs gruppen
durchaus mit einbezogen werden und da
hat hamburg eben gesagt zum beispiel für
uns wäre sehr wichtig jetzt mal an
alleinerziehende mehr zu denken das
wollen wir auch tun und die anderen
bundesländern müssen das tun was in
ihren möglichkeiten steht zumal die
korona pause viele probleme schafft
häusliche gewalt gegen kinder ist ein
großes sorgenkind der jugendämter
auch dürfen kinder mit speziellem
förderbedarf den anschluss nicht
verlieren
das gilt für die sprachförderung von
geflüchteten ebenso wie für kinder mit
bewegungsdrang wenn die kinder nicht
langsam wieder in die kita zurück kommt
müssen wir über andere wege nachdenken
ob sie vielleicht noch ein jahr länger
in der kita bleiben damit man ihnen ihre
startchancen für ihr ganzes leben nicht
dadurch nimmt dass man sie so lange von
diesem wichtigen ort kita ferngehalten
hat zumal die kitas schon jetzt die
vorgaben in größerem stil einhalten
könnten gruppen bis fünf kinder sind die
vorgabe wie viele dieser kleinen gruppen
ist parallel geben kann hängt aber
allein vom jeweiligen gebäude ab um den
kontakt nicht zu verlieren telefonieren
die erzieherinnen viel mit den familien
oder lassen sich die wohnzimmer kita
einfallen jeden tag ein volles
kindergarten programm per internet video
an der kreativität in den einrichtungen
mangelt es jedenfalls nicht
die länder der eu sollen ab sofort an
einem strang ziehen um die korona
pandemie zu bewältigen
das fordert das eu parlament und
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen
hält eine aufstockung des nächsten eu
haushalts für den einzigen weg aus der
krise zu beginn der sondersendung
entschuldigte sie sich im namen europas
zwei italien das land hätte zu beginn
der pandemie mehr unterstützung erfahren
müssen
im streit um die arbeit der
weltgesundheitsorganisation hat sich
bundeskanzlerin merkel heute
demonstrativ hinter die whu gestellt und
zwar nach ihren gesprächen mit den
kollegen der sieben führenden
industrienationen schon zum zweiten mal
in der korona krise schalteten sich die
spitzen frankreichs deutschlands
italiens großbritanniens japans kanadas
und der usa per video zusammen
us-präsident trump hatte vorgestern die
zahlungen an die bh eingestellt auch in
seinem eigenen land geht trump wohl auf
konfrontationskurs
er will nämlich dass das öffentliche
leben in den bundesstaaten möglichst
rasch wieder hochgefahren wird
und das geht vielen gouverneuren zu
schnell
zwar sehen auch sie dass die folgen der
krise für die us-wirtschaft enorm sind
der gesundheitsschutz für die
bevölkerung sei aber weitaus wichtiger
ines trams berichtet aus washington sie
wollen raus sich wieder treffen sie
fordern dass die geschäfte aufmachen sie
wollen wieder arbeiten
trump anhänger demonstrieren in michigan
für ein schnelles hochfahren der
wirtschaft die anordnungen um das corona
virus einzudämmen
die halten sie für übertrieben meine
tochter und mein schwiegersohn sind
kleinunternehmer und es bringt sich
schlicht um und sollte das mit gesundem
menschenverstand machen
ich muss rechnungen bezahlen und so wie
es mich und meine familie trifft zur
betrifft es auch tausende und millionen
von anderen familien präsident trump
hört seine wähler schließlich ist war ja
eher drängt darauf die einschränkungen
zügig aufzuheben am nachmittag will er
neue richtlinien bekannt geben
es gibt ermutigende entwicklungen wir
sind in einer starken position neue
regeln zu verabschieden um das land
wieder hochzufahren
einige bundesstaaten werden wir sehr
viel früher öffnen kann als andere
sicherlich schon vor dem stichtag ersten
mal binnen einer woche melden sich
nochmals rund 5 millionen arbeitslos
insgesamt sind nun 22 millionen ohne job
dennoch die gouverneure der
bundesstaaten sie sorgen sich vor einer
zu schnellen rückkehr zum alltag
lasst uns nicht den fehler machen den
stecker zu früh zu ziehen und sehr wir
das alle auch wollen
ich fürchte wenn wir
alles zu früh aufmachen ohne dem virus
zuvor das genick gebrochen zu haben
dann ließen wir benzin ins feuer wenn
auch unbeabsichtigt erschreckend lang
die schlangen an den ausgaben für
kostenlose lebensmittel der druck auf
die politik ist groß abzuwägen zwischen
wirtschaft und risiko für die gesundheit
hilfen für die wirtschaft schutzschirme
sofort zahlungen das sind instrumente
mit den industriestaaten versuchen in
zeiten von corona das schlimmste zu
verhindern
arme länder etwa in afrika können all
das nicht ausgangssperren bedeuten dort
oft keine chance überhaupt geld zu
verdienen und oft genug hunger
unsere korrespondentin sandra times
berichtet über simbabwe wo die
arbeitslosigkeit schon in normalen
zeiten auf über 80 prozent geschätzt
wird
das geschäftsviertel in harare verweist
märkte geschlossen
die wirtschaft lag schon vor der korona
pandemie am boden
jetzt nimmt die ausgangssperre den
meisten händlern die möglichkeit auch
nur ein bisschen geld zu verdienen
während der ausgangssperre können wir
nicht arbeiten
wir sind nur hier um unsere waren zu
schützen falls jemand die ausgangssperre
nutzen sollte um uns zu bestehen
das alles schadet dem geschäft wir leben
von der hand in den mund
[Musik]
nach jahrzehnten der misswirtschaft und
einer schweren dürre sind schätzungen
zufolge mehr als ein drittel der
bevölkerung von hunger bedroht die
ausgangssperre vergrößert ihre not die
regierung muss uns essen geben oder geld
das ist das was wir am dringendsten
brauchen auch das gesundheitssystem ist
katastrophal
es gibt kaum intensivbetten und
beatmungsgeräte schutzausrüstung ist
mangelware die ärzte schlagen alarm
es gibt einen unterschied zwischen
heldentum und selbstmord wir müssen
zuerst uns selbst schützen um den
patienten helfen zu können
wir sagen zuerst brauchen wir schutz aus
hast du dann können wir unsere hilfe
anbieten
die krankenhausärzte warnten schon ende
letzten jahres dass patienten sterben
weil es in den kliniken an allem fehle
jetzt auch noch corona simbabwe ist
denkbar schlecht gerüstet
es ist noch mehr passiert an diesem
donnerstag so könnte polen ein
schärferes abtreibungsrecht bekommen
ein entsprechender gesetzentwurf hat die
erste hürde im parlament genommen
künftig sollen frauen auch dann nicht
abtreiben dürfen wenn der fötus schwer
missgebildet ist natalie steger
es ist ihr protest ja nur so aussehen
kann in corona zeiten mit abstand große
demonstrationen unmöglich die frauen
befürchten eine verschärfung des
polnischen abtreibungsrechts das ohnehin
eines der strengsten in europa ist
ich weiß nicht was sie machen aber
zumindest werden sie uns hören nur im
falle von vergewaltigung ist abtreibung
legal wenn gesundheit oder leben der
werdenden mutter bedroht ist oder der
fötus missbildungen hat letzteres
schwere fotos schäden soll kein legaler
abtreibungs grund mehr sein so steht es
in einem gesetzentwurf der auf eine
initiative von erz konservativen bürgern
zurück geht die dafür unterschriften
sammelten dass kinder vor ihrer geburt
umgebracht werden ist fundamental es
bewegt zutiefst die herzen von guten
menschen
die nationalkonservative
regierungspartei ps ist im grunde für
den vorschlag polens katholische kirche
uni schon 2016 war die pis für eine
verschärfung des abtreibungsrechts aber
nach großen protesten von
hunderttausenden polinnen war die ps
zurückgerudert
nun ist das thema erneut auf der
tagesordnung die opposition zeigt sich
entsetzt
ich bin kein unterstützer von abtreibung
aber ich bin ein entschiedener gegner
dass man frauen ihre rechte nimmt und
das gesetz rasch die pis hatte den
gesetzentwurf zwar gebilligt aber in
einem ausschuss gepackt und wind ihn
vorerst nicht durch denn einerseits muss
man die konservative wählerschaft
bedienen will aber andererseits nicht
nur einmal einknicken müssen vor der wut
der frauen polens
die vergewaltigung einer 18-jährigen in
mülheim an der ruhr hat im vergangenen
sommer bundesweit entsetzen ausgelöst
die täter 12 bis 15 jahre alt heute hat
das landgericht duisburg das urteil
gesprochen
einer der jugendlichen muss für
zweieinhalb jahre ins gefängnis zwei
andere für vier wochen in dauerarrest
thomas münten berichtet auf diesem
spielplatz in der mülheimer innenstadt
soll sich die tat im sommer 2009 10
ereignet haben
nach ansicht des gerichtes haben fünf
bulgare ständige jugendliche hier eine
18 jährige vergewaltigt zwei der
beschuldigten konnten nicht verfolgt
werden
sie waren zum tatzeitpunkt noch nicht
strafmündig die jugendlichen behaupteten
über den gesamten prozess verlauf alles
sei einvernehmlich passiert das sahen
die richter anders
die geschädigte mit dem sexuellen
handlungen zunächst noch einverstanden
war
spätestens als es zu gewalthandlungen
kam war sie damit aber nicht mehr
einverstanden
trotzdem haben die drei angeklagten und
einer der beiden zwölfjährigen die
geschädigte weiterungen zu sexuellen
handlungen gezwungen
der damals 15-jährige haupttäter muss
für zweieinhalb jahre in jugendhaft zwei
der mittäter erhielten hohe
bewährungsstrafen plus arrest die
familie des haupttäters sollte
zwischenzeitlich wegen gefälschter
arbeitspapiere abgeschoben werden
unmittelbar vor der ausreise konnte der
familienvater jedoch einen echten
arbeitsvertrag als reinigungskraft
vorweisen
daheim bleiben für viele ist das ja nun
alltag offenbar auch für den street art
künstler banksy der gestaltete ein
badezimmer um mit gemalten ratten und
einem echten chaos immerhin gibt es noch
hygiene-artikel banks kommentar meine
frau hasst es wenn ich von zu hause aus
arbeite auch wenn es wohl nicht wirklich
das bad des anonym stars ist scheint die
botschaft klar beschränkungen verwandeln
auf dauer jede zivilisation in einen zoo
so weit sind wir aber noch lange nicht
gleich kommt noch das wetter mit gunther
tiersch sehr viel sonne für die nächsten
tage verheißt und anschließend unser
spezial zur krise um 22 uhr informiert
sie marietta slomka dem heute journal
ich danke ihnen für interesse wünsche
ihnen noch
schönen abend und freue mich morgen
wieder auf sie
[Musik]
guten abend liebe zuschauer im süden
wird es jetzt morgen wolkiger und es
kann auch vereinzelte schauer geben
im norden ändert sich kaum etwas da
bleibt der himmel meist wolkenlos
norddeutschland liegt mehr in der nähe
dieses hochdruckgebiet ist da kommt ja
die kühle luft aus norden aber in den
süden fließt weiterhin warme und jetzt
auch feuchte luft da kann es also dann
morgen nachmittag auch mal regenschauer
geben
heute nacht ist es noch sternen klar es
wird ein bisschen locker bewölkt hier im
südwesten da bleibt es auch am mildesten
während es in schleswig holstein auch
leichten frost gibt bis minus 1 grad und
tagsüber bleibt es dann in der
nordhälfte deutlich kühler als im süden
da sind es 11 bis 17 oder 18 grad in der
südhälfte 19 bis 26 grad ganz ähnlich
wie heute und es ist ein freundlich ein
sonniger vormittag auf jeden fall im
süden haben wir schon ein paar
wolkenfelder dabei und zum nachmittag
bilden sich über den mittelgebirgen dann
vereinzelte regenschauer und dazu weht
auch nur ein schwacher nordwind die
aussichten die schauer vom wären mehr am
samstag in der mitte und im süden
vereinzelte gewitter sonntag dann nur
noch an den alpen der wind dreht auf
nordost wird stärker und dann wird es
aus osten etwas kühler
ich wünschen noch einen schönen abend
und machen sie's gut